salut nous sommes samedi matin il est 11
heures c'est pour ça qu ici dans ma
fenêtre
il fait encore nuit hier dans la vidéo
je vous ai parlé de la prise de décision
à pile ou face aujourd'hui c'est
différent puisque je vous apprends à
bluffer quelqu'un ou du moins est encore
plus performant dans vos arnaque avec
vos amis et ça je tenais à vous dire
c'est pas beau on peut aller en enfer
pour ça donc c'est purement pour la
culture générale mais il existe une
technique pour gagner à pile ou face
génériques
initialement on pense que les chances
sont équitables pour gagner à pile ou
face c'est pile ou s'efface donc c'est
50 % ou 50 %
esi et c'est vrai c'est complètement
vrai mais on peut changer la donne à
notre avantage vous explique comment un
peu comme dans la vidéo sur le chiffon
me dont je vous mets le lien ici si vous
n'avez pas vu cette formidable
production de fabien olicard du mental
blog je vais vous donner tout un
processus qui va vous permettre de faire
ce jeu n'importe quand en ayant un
maximum de chances de votre côté
imaginez vous êtes avec un ami n'importe
quoi vous voulez lancer une partie de
pile ou face et surtout vous voulez la
gagner ben oui tu m'étonnes la première
chose à faire c'est que vous n'avez pas
parier que sur piles ou que surface vous
proposer une amélioration du jeu et vous
allez choisir chacun une séquence de
trois résultats donc ça peut être pil
pil pil pil face face aux piles facile
en fait il ya deux puissances trois
possibilités huit possibilités de
puissance 3 c'est pareil ensuite on
lance la pièce plein de fois sur comme
le pile ou face classique quoi et vous
notez les résultats sur un bout de
papier ou juste mentalement jusqu'à
temps que l'une de vos deux séquences
apparaissent parfois ça peut sortir en
trois coups parfois offrir une dizaine
ou une douzaine de coups avant que l'une
des deux séquences pile face face à
ganges que vous auriez choisi sorte et
c'est là qu'on atteint les limites de
notre cerveau parce que intuitivement on
pense qu'on a les mêmes chances que ça
peu près équitable et c'est complètement
faux de les statistiques nous prouve le
contraire
alors rassurez vous je vais pas vous
faire la grosse démonstration
mathématique qui va vous permettre de
bien comprendre pourquoi les
statistiques nous donne raison dans ces
cas là je vous donner le résultat final
applicable et gagnant vous aurez ensuite
en appliquant cette méthode trois
chances sur quatre de gagner au jeu du
pile ou face
la première étape et il ya que deux
étapes donc servas tranquille la
première étape je disais c'est que c'est
l'autre personne qui va commencer par
choisir sa séquence ensuite vous allez
donner votre séquence de trois résultats
sur trois lancers sauf que votre réponse
dépend directement de la séquence qu'il
a choisi ce que c'est
bien clair pas tellement explications
plus précises si votre adversaire
choisit face face face alors on va se
donner un code on va dire fff s'il
choisit fff
vous vous choisissez pff pour qu'ils
fassent face en faisant ça vous aurez
écoutez moi bien cette chance sur 8 de
gagner s'il choisit ffp vous choisissez
pff
et là vous aurez quand même trois
chances sur quatre de gagner 75 %
vis-à-vis des 50% le départ ci prend fpf
vous prenez ffp et je vous fais les cinq
derniers plus rapidement et de toute
manière je vous le mets dans la
description s'il prend fpp vous prenez
ffp ci prend pff
vous prenez ppf ci prend pfp vous prenez
ppf également il prend ppf alors vous
prenez fpp trois chances sur quatre est
enfin s'y prend ppp pil pil pil vous
prenez fpp face pil pil
et là c'est encore une fois cette chance
sur 8 de gagner si vous voulez que je
vous trouve un moyen mnémotechnique de
retenir ça ou que je vous donne des
astuces pour vous faire une bidoche
lorsque vous faites le jeu de manière un
petit peu subtile vous me le dites dans
les commentaires je me ferai un plaisir
de faire une suite à cette vidéo quoi
qu'il arrive si ça vous plaît d'avoir ce
genre de technique beaucoup et me le
faire savoir en laissant indélicat ou
sans l'air du week-end en plus il fait
plaisir
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
à la chaîne avant de partir puisque le
mental voit que c'est une vidéo par jour
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 11 heures hé ouais
les mecs les dimanches sont 11e rendez
vous demain à 11h ciao
comme ça
là